[موسيقى]
هنا يمكنك ان تلمس معجزات تنطق بها الارض
قالها فريق انقاذ الماني يعمل في تركيا
رابط انساني عجيب بين عمال الانقاذ وضحايا
الزلزال
دون ساعات طويله يتحدثون الى المنكوبين
يحاولون التخفيف من الامهم حينما واحيانا
كثيره يلقون اليهم باي وسيله ممكنه قد
تعيد اليهم الامل من جديد
زينب كرهمان السيده التي خرجت على قيد
الحياه بعد اربع ساعات تحدت خلالها البرده
وانعدام اسباب الحياه بعد يوم من انقاذها
تلقت فرق الانقاذ خبر وفاتها
التزموا الصمت دعوه يكررها المنقذون
للمتجمهرين حول حطام المباني لعلهم يدركون
استغاثه ناج هنا او هناك
وخلال احدى لحظات الصمت تلك تحديدا في
قهرمان مرعش انتبه عمال الانقاذ لمعجزه
جديده
عائشه الطفله ذات السبعه اعوام خاضت صراعا
طويلا لمده سته ايام وسط امل وخوف اطبق
على المكان لساعات طويله لتولد من جديد
التشبث بالحياه رساله يواصل كتابه سطورها
من هم تحت الانقاض فهذا الرضيع الذي يبلغ
من العمر شهرين خرج حيا وسط الذهول كل من
يتابع المشهد
سيد الحديدي العربيه